halo ODST troopers of halo 3 I am
Rorschach from the watchman a Mad Hatter
and Alice from american mcgee's alice
the video game what do you guys dressed
as you're Cylons fantastic I'm a
symbiote suit spider-man how exactly did
you go from a normal spider-man to the
dark creature i see before me nobody
really knows for the classic red shirt
basically you're the unnamed crewman who
beans down to the planet and eventually
dies so that the heroes can come back
and save today Catwoman yeah Catwoman
okay i guess that Sally Jupiter from
watchmen right I am Kid Icarus he has a
game way back then his name is kid
icarus this he's an angel I just walking
by than some zombies came out of nowhere
and bit me the leg and Here I am
you